pour parler en direct avec nous paul
thompson vice-président du parti
conservateur britannique en france
bonjour monsieur thomson merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
bruxelles le mot c'est l'ombre les deux
semblent jusqu'au boutiste dans ce
contexte si aucun ne va à vers l'autre
et c'est ce qui apparaît un saumon il
sera très très difficile de trouver
d'accord oui je pense que on est
toujours que plus les méfaits le cas
depuis des mois -dans un une situation
de confrontation politique et dans une
certaine mesure de théâtre politique
mais c'est nous faut pas s'en offusquer
cette partie du jeu il ya cinq jours
madame fendre l'air à tiques les les
choses étaient bien avancées qu'il avait
un texte sur un texte juridique sur la
table ça veut c'est déjà un signe plutôt
positif
ces trois sujets sont politiquement
sensibles pour la france notamment la
question de la pêche est sensible parce
que même si économiquement ce n'était
pas très haut dans l'économie française
il y a des certaines régions la bretagne
ou normandie je crois où il ya un
secteur de tâches qui dépend des eaux
territoriales britanniques et parce que
depuis des décennies il est un système
de quotas et donc c'est politiquement
sensible en france notamment dans
belgique aussi
et en ce qui concerne la question de la
de l'intégrité du marché unique en fait
7,1 formule qui d'une certaine façon ne
veut rien dire
dans ce sens que le royaume uni
ne sera plus dans le marché unique donc
donc pavé de l'intégrer d'une hache
unique pour un pays qui n'en fait pas
partie est un non sens
on comprend son raisonnement son
véritable raisonnement c'est que elle ne
veut pas que alors oui il soit plus
compétitif que les membres du marché
commun mais ç'a paru de l'hymne européen
mais ça c'est une question de toutes
sortes facteurs économiques loire muni
gudrat je pense encourager certains
industries de pointe mais c'est le cas
de l'union européenne aussi des
etats-unis du japon
tout ça c'est le jeu normal de la
compétition entre pays
donc il est normal qu'une telle
compétition existe en fait je garde bon
espoir que les parties à vous arrive un
solution quand même parce que c'est dans
l'intérêt des deux côtés alors si jamais
il n'y avait pas d'accord avec mon
n'arrive rien new deal qui serait le
plus perdant dans la serre londres ou
bruxelles
les deux serait franchement perdant mais
je pense
bon ça difficile de répondre à cette
question mais vous pour ma part j'ai
tendance à penser que ce serait plutôt
bruxelles parce que cela créerait des
tensions politiques à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne parce que tel pays
seraient davantage touché par par tel
autre pays et le et donc sacré raid et
les difficultés politiques pour le bon
fonctionnement de l'union européenne et
le royaume uni serait certainement très
significativement touchée aussi dans ce
serait vraiment scénario de pertes
perdant donc espérons que on en arrive
pas là
paul thompson merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions de rappelle que vous êtes
vice-président du parti conservateur
britannique en france merci
il m'a pris